what's going on you guys lord addict
here we're
on episode three of
death's door last episode we defeated a
boss
we went around the the lost cemetery our
cemetery
definitely butchered that again in this
episode it looks like we're going to
try to pursue some of these other leads
that's in this game
uh so apparently what's going on is we
have to collect
three big souls to open this death's
door so
so you know keep that in mind i don't
know if you could do
any of them individually or you have to
go to a certain direction
or you could kill any other that you
want and they the rest just level up
i would assume that it's going to be
like one of those scenarios where you
have to have certain items to get to
certain places
so i don't think we'll be really you
know crossing that too much
so hopefully i i want to fight the witch
i don't know why but fighting witches
and games all
always are pretty decently fun so let's
let's look for these things man let's
let's find this witch or i think the
second one was a witch
man i don't remember exactly what he
said it was a witch
i think it was a beast and like a knight
or something like that something related
to those
individual ones now oddly enough i don't
remember a hundred percent
of what was going on the last time i
played this game
so we're gonna have to look for that but
i do remember not going
okay so we did go over here that's where
we talked to
him and he just pretty much told us the
scenario that's going on we have to find
three other big large souls in order to
be able to
open that door
this door requires a key old and rusted
so we need a old and rusted key
[Music]
this way leads to them oh a mansion okay
so they they
they word in this stuff all right so we
already found the witch's lair
we already found the witch's leg
this is a very creepy looking layer
i like the the aesthetics man the
aesthetics is a very
unique thing here
all right so what is this
what's going on that's fine we got him
here's a little lever here
so that started that i don't know what
that did besides start that
okay
i think you need an item here to burn
these cobwebs
still lost a little bit but we'll find
something
do i no i don't open that again
let's look around can you break this
no you can't and you clearly can't go
through that
i think this is the entrance yeah
maybe we can't come here till we have a
certain item let's see these tombstones
i feel like we have to do something man
oh here's another one i'm an idiot
i'm just gonna like that yep open this
up
what is this oh okay
i thought it was locked for some reason
like you couldn't go in it yet
but that's not how it is man
oh what are these
something's about to happen oh we just
came outside
maybe this leads to a big house because
it said leads to the mansion
yeah it's looking like it's leading to a
house
here's like the little feathers
burn your weapon and spread joy
okay
burn my weapon and spread joy
let's break these and see if we can find
something
[Music]
burn my weapon and spread joy
[Music]
all right okay hold up
[Music]
maybe i shoot this thing next to us
he does have a bow so it would make
sense let's wait for this to regenerate
does it regenerate
[Music]
come on
about to leave the area and come back
how is this work how do i get my arrows
back
oh
i hit that that part and i think i got
one
so let's see
[Music]
okay but i got no more arrows
i say to the urine which
[Music]
hold up
probably got a time limit
[Music]
that's how you get in that um there's a
couple of those things throughout the
map
so i'm assuming that's how you progress
through those areas
what is this oh it's just another door
i don't need that particularly right now
oh hello there my beat faced your fellow
is it quite useful to use one of those
things of isles i imagine you must be
here for a soul
not me i hope anyways it seems our past
have uh
intersected as an opportune moment you
may have noticed that i have been cursed
with an unusual affliction
atlas judge me not by the shape of my
head by the
the deliciousness of the soup inside
pothead oh my god
where's my matters i'm very pleased to
make your acquaintance big face
he's got soup in his head it would seem
that my journey has reached an impasse
i haven't been able to overcome the
obstacles and unlock the iron gates
if you want to help me move i will be
ended over to you and we could push
forward together
can i hit him no
no need to hit him now
got some more uh fire stuff so where's
the first fire one there it is
i gotta find some more arrows i can't do
it with just one
all right so you probably probably have
to do this quick so let's try to do this
quick
[Music]
one two
three
[Music]
i'm not worried about you right now
i'm worried about the the end of time
man and you guys look like you're pretty
slow so i'm not worried about you
fighting yet either
quick work man quick work
[Music]
oh look what they do oh this thing has
this thing
this thing a little bit fast
[Music]
he's got a wizard someone shooting a
fire arrow at me
come on
[Music]
where is he
not letting me go that easy
got you
i wonder if that's the iron gates he was
referring to
what does this one say the garden of joy
all right so didn't have nothing else
besides saying the garden of joy okay
what is this
oh okay hold up
let's not get too close to those again
we ain't trying to take that kind of
damage now
oh let's go let's go
yeah you probably should have thought
about that a little bit more
let's go back for that hell thing that
was at the beginning of this
because i planted it but i didn't do
anything with it let's go back for that
[Music]
there we go
going through the garden of joy well i
don't know if this
part is part of the garden of joy but we
getting somewhere man we're getting some
[Music]
i like the aesthetics man
so far so good there's a lever
what happened
[Music]
oh we need another one okay so we need
to unlock two of them
he seemed to have moved much impressive
make sure hastening not the second
lantern
i feel like i'm about to fight this dude
i don't know why but part of me feels
like
he's on some suspect stuff
[Music]
okay so i can't do that
let's go buddy one
two
got to do with the arrow
light work got the mage
ow where are you oh there you are
one arrow two
let's arrow him
[Music]
let's plant the seed so i can get some
health here in a second
i'll come back for that when i take a
couple more heads
come over here there we go
let's get to do with oh there's a lot
here let's let's get the mage
the mages first i feel like they're
easiest to hit
okay maybe let's go back for hell
let's just separate this dude separate
kill him
kill the other archer
come on
kill him
[Music]
open that shortcut for later
[Music]
there's another bow dude another mage
[Music]
ow i don't know how he hit me
i'm sure that's so over here
[Music]
got another lever man another lever
well we can venture onwards my stupid
companion but first
we shall greet ourselves a moment of
recipe come sit with me a while
uh maybe i don't want to do this as i
mentioned upon our meeting
i was not always quite so earthwave in
appearance
this strange curse has visited me upon
the wicked lady who resides in the
mansion beyond these lyric
gardens i imagine you are here for her
or you not
surely her soul must be swollen ripped
for reaping due to her unnatural
extended years i desire not to be
confronted by the old witch in a punch
undo her chromatic definitely butchered
that deed and restored me to my formal
handsome self
i was quite the looker you know
soup no
so it be let us push on forward
interesting
[Music]
oh what was that that was
oh
[Music]
i definitely ain't feeling what they
just did there they beat my curiosity
man
yeah i need this
[Music]
oh so that automatically comes to me it
doesn't hit them like the purple one
[Music]
oh i don't want to hit that i knew i was
gonna hit it
[Music]
[Music]
ow
[Music]
they're not too fast
no
i like how their dead bodies stay there
i'm pretty sure i've stated that in the
past but
it gives it like a little bit more of a
cinematic feel if their dead body stays
there
i would good would i not
i have a feeling this is the boss i
don't know why so here we are
it would be coming however keep your
what's about you until dangerous place
inside let us drive into the procession
uh venture and enter the belly of the
beast together he might not be he might
literally just been someone that's
been done wrong
[Music]
what is this
that was weird
[Music]
it's a little weird but
we're not gonna question it man we're
not gonna question
[Music]
looks like they regenerate eventually
yeah see
interesting mechanic what is this looks
like a big door
a living reaper i hunger for souls i
don't know what that's about
a key to open
[Music]
if they all could come back like that
it's interesting i i can whatever kind
of mechanic they're gonna want for me in
this game
in this level
i assume this is where the wood shits
something stopping me of the door from
opening
oh this thing
oh look at you trying
you trying man you're trying not very
well but you're trying
am i hitting none of these
there's seems to be two probably this
witch in a pod somewhere
let's check them all boys
interesting
[Music]
there we go
oh god i bet you he could have gotten a
pot
and took it over again if i would let
him
[Music]
nothing to see there let's climb these
looks like there might be a little fire
puzzle in here somewhere
[Music]
not too too bad see if this isn't a live
part
it's not got a key
looks like something's preventing me
from getting it
oh i gotta activate two
interesting i wonder if i can
shoot from this one to that one
yeah you can okay
got the key
all right so this is an interesting
little room
okay let's get let's keep going let's
look around more
[Music]
okay what is that about
all right you got to do these to get on
to this
[Music]
i don't know what more they want from me
well what is this over here hold up
[Music]
oh in order to active we gotta get all
these purple pods
i think there's one over here
yep
[Music]
let's keep going guys let's keep doing
it
oh what's going on here
it seems like we're in a
[Music]
a more darker end of this place
uh i wonder if i could shoot through
those boxes or like blow them up or
something
i'll hold up now
let's go over here
[Music]
[Music]
i don't have any hold up there we go
might be one of the reasons that uh
these things keep coming back because
they want to always
give you options to be able to get more
arrows
[Music]
i feel like there should be like a
a sound to kind of demonstrate that you
solved the puzzle if that makes sense to
you guys oh
what is this what you got going on
buddy oh
this thing can break it can break
what you doing are you shooting one of
these things at me
oh can you stop chasing me man
thank you let's break this again though
because you're not that smart
you're not that guy buddy you're not
that guy
you're not that guy buddy
you're not that guy
i told him he wasn't that guy he didn't
believe me
[Music]
he just wasn't that guy guys
[Music]
i free the soul it appears we've
abandoned uh
we've been abandoned i don't think
anyone is coming to open the door
is that a chicken something
[Music]
seems like we need four souls to open
that
door
[Music]
oh what is this hello dear unexpected to
see a crow around this place does this
mean the deal is off
what brings an adorable fella like you
into my little house
oh look at him running look at her
running
[Music]
[Music]
ah let's not hit that again
the witch was kind of scary man i'm
gonna be real with you guys
[Music]
uh i assume
same concept
oh move move
uh i really could use some health
and be real with you guys i could use
some help
[Music]
gotcha
so we do gotta find two more of those
[Music]
i'm not trying to fight anything like
that
i'm just trying to find the two things
to open that door
[Music]
and one's right there
[Music]
it's nice little uh mechanics man i'm
not gonna lie nice little mechanics
uh okay i'm
i gotta kill this thing hold up
[Music]
got it open sesame
[Music]
i need a part one of those pop things
oh there's one right there how do i get
up there
[Music]
i could really really use that part
is there a way up there
[Music]
clearly this particular episode is going
to be a little bit longer than usual
[Music]
all right so i got that
let me go up here
let me go get that pot i don't think i
could shoot down
at a spiral like that
but i do need that health man i need the
health pretty bad
[Music]
see what this does
all right so that's like a shortcut
kinda
well another uh another one of these
things told you guys you ain't that guy
oh so your plan is to jump me
but considering you couldn't do a whole
lot before i guess jump is better than
nothing
yo guys ain't that god
they just ain't that they ain't them
guys man
i'm trying to eat me though it's kind of
weird
let's get away from all of this
you ain't that god
[Music]
took your people a minute to even hit me
gotcha
they just quick work man quick work
freed another soul she said i would live
forever but with a pulp
for a head no thanks
clearly i need to release for these
souls
and then that will lead to opening that
door and chances are the witch is in
that door
[Music]
interesting concept i need that oh
heavens my house is a mess my beautiful
urn
shattered oh i mean i must apologize for
the state of the house dearly i wasn't
expecting guests
stop it i didn't ask for your your
nonsense
but there is a key i gotta get
the key is important
[Music]
uh let me see how i can get this key
now how do i can i like get it at an
angle to get that
there's got to be a way to reach that
i think an angle
okay an angle
yep see angle
i wonder where that which one
[Music]
what is this oh it's one of those
so pick up things
[Music]
what you want bud goodness look at the
door the voids are starting to glow
was that done down to you something you
found during your exploration of course
it was
going on within the other wings perhaps
you'll find even more
i got you my dude
[Music]
hmm
[Music]
also they all came out when i when one
of them
uh
i got you i could probably use that let
me find a way up there
always use health man never pass free
health
hmm it's another key
[Music]
got another golden key
i assume that's for a door somewhere
[Music]
uh one of the boom doors
there's another one get that get on the
bed
open sesame
this video is going to take like forever
to upload to youtube
especially if i die
run run run as fast as you can
[Music]
you guys can't out shoot me
i don't know who you think you're trying
to play with
[Music]
oh it's another one of these things
let's get your butt oh it's witches okay
this might be a little bit more
complicated
because the witches can be a lot harder
to fight
get a couple of clicks in
[Music]
let's try to keep just one at a time and
keep it moving
[Music]
get a little bit of hits in
oh
[Music]
i gotta get rid of him cuz the witches
are just gonna keep getting respawn
[Music]
got him let's get rid of these witches
kind of remind me of the witches from uh
zelda the pose
there's a little sweating a little bit
just a little bit not much just a little
bit
not a lot just a little bit yeah i don't
care what you guys have to say anymore
i get the gist collect four souls go in
the door
now that witch is gonna be in this room
again
if they keep up with their mo
probably in the yep oh goodness you're
not the cause of all this process are
you
i should not be very hostile to any
beasts who would mistreat my children
tread lightly
[Music]
i like how she don't like try to fight
me
she know better she know what's up
[Music]
what does these doors lead to
oh what is this oh there's a lever here
[Music]
oh this probably is a yes shortcut back
to the entrance
[Music]
it looks like that's the last door
[Music]
how it goes exploration the mansion is
dark and full of strange creatures
please stay vigilant i wouldn't have a
new companion in great years so i do not
know how to survive my first adventure
together
you ain't done nothing this whole game
fam you'll be fine
where's that source of light coming from
uh
[Music]
where is it coming from
[Music]
okay so that's not it
[Music]
gotta figure out where this last
door is
maybe i just continue going that path
because there was more to that room
it's just that was like a shortcut back
up here
[Music]
because i've never been to this room
oh it's a big one okay what does he want
shall we dance
oh god
[Music]
yeah i'ma get some health before i fight
this thing i'm running
i know but to me man it's not worth the
death
it's just not let's get this seed
then we'll go down there and we'll see
what's up
[Music]
i hit you through this
can you not even come out of there
[Music]
[Music]
oh my god he's so fast
[Music]
now you do like a little diagonal stuff
he can't really do a whole lot
yeah see he's like a like a tip top
thing what are the things they're called
[Music]
can't really do a whole lot of candy
there my my my friend
[Music]
yeah a little kind of little pathetic
after you learned them
he hit me that one time and i realized
how
how bad his character's on was they
should have had him like jump up in the
air or something like that too
i felt like that was a little bit too
easy
i don't know that's just me
[Music]
something's going on there
[Music]
open those doors let's grab this
ow
i ain't trying to do none of that
oh okay there's there's pipes
start lighting this stuff up though
it's kind of unique
a little bit
there's a lot of man
one more oh it's the top head people
[Music]
that kind of scared me for a little bit
i'm doing something right now
[Music]
all right opening that up
here's another one of these we could
always use some more health
[Music]
they're gonna make me fight something
after i get the soul
why did the door close how did you get
back
[Music]
now that door is gonna open
uh no no fight no fight okay
well you little crow you have well
understood you're welcome first you
tricked my grand grandson or trey and
then
nonsense of this curse and then you come
in here and smash all my beautiful urns
i'm just trying to help people i if you
set foot
in my basement there would be
consequences i might even have words of
your employer although i rather not
see the old that old weirdo again i mean
a lot for her head
so strange off with your little pro
it's kind of weird she she does know us
see where this goes maybe it's like a
secret or it's just a shortcut
oh it's it's a secret get some extra
some extra extra oh what is that
this wasn't open earlier okay
[Music]
let's go ahead and go back to the um
little pro
place
got it upgrade man gotta upgrade
all right these doors just spawn
everywhere i feel like they should have
been there from the start you just
couldn't access them
i like my speed man i like my speed
i feel more comfortable when i'm fast in
this game
i don't know if they're gonna let i
don't know if um
all right let's see what happens all the
voids are going on earthy is it unlocked
if only i had more complete
understanding of the door before you
perceive rick i have a commit confession
to make
the old witch of this house she is my
grandmother she cursed me with this
in this guide effort to make me immortal
you see she would be struggling with
grief when my
grandfather passed and made her mission
to keep her whole family alive
[Music]
okay so pretty much her she has swollen
crap i've seen her as a reaper i pull
you
to end her suffering perhaps she can
find peace again
so pretty much she
she she had like a mental breakdown
and that's why all this is going on okay
so they're trying to make you feel bad
for the
for the bad guy a little bit i can
understand that
what is this
[Music]
what's going on
oh oh
did i just die
apres
[Music]
your own thing against you
i need to stop being so hasty
[Music]
oh my god witches
[Music]
oh so they don't even try to attack you
oh my god man that's a lot of stuff
going on
[Music]
let's do this
let's try to shoot these green things
more back instead of
us risking our life to fight
[Music]
[Music]
i can't get hit again
[Music]
come on
[Music]
oh my god man i rolled right into him
[Music]
right into him i could really use
a health or something
four way
[Music]
oh my god
[Music]
i can't get hit one more way one more oh
god
this isn't fun
[Music]
i don't even know what to do here let's
kill the little ones first
i just hope when i kill these these
things that like they don't come
back that'd be unfortunate
[Music]
all right so are they coming back
[Music]
i don't think they are
[Music]
they're not coming back we're good
put down the shield thing man sir
[Music]
put down the shield
[Music]
we demand shields
[Music]
there you go
got him got him
hopefully this chest will spit me out
since i completed this little trial
oh what is this it looks like a big crow
a gift to a fellow pro to aid you in
your quest so that's how you get like
[Music]
crazy
[Music]
i don't know what this does flame square
required
back to arrows okay
i like that that's nice that's nice
oh so i can literally just light them
okay
[Music]
i wonder why her domain
is in looks like it's the realm that
they're from
they're weird
i see you've been exploring the old
office departments
i used to work over in the uh the east
the uh e section before i embraced my
true life
to quit the right race i'm much happier
now i'm delivered love casting life
okay
okay so what just happened
oh i need that to open that door yeah
these things
that's why
she said the basement
man it's about to take like two hours to
upload man
probably longer than that
you know we might go ahead and uh we'll
go ahead and call it quits for this
episode because we are 51 minutes in
i went way over than than the the
potential one i like doing i usually
like keeping them
30 20 30 minutes long but we're gonna go
and end this one
and uh we'll see you for the next
episode